the presidency of Donald Trump the man
voted least edible by cannibal magazine
six years in the road and I know I
honestly know that the prospect of
talking about Trump yet again feels
exhausting we're all so tired of him
every room in America should have a sign
on the wall that counts the number of
minutes that it's been since someone
brought up his name but but that
is the thing Trump's presidency is like
one of his handshakes it pulls you in
whether you like it or not he's had so
many terrible moments this year you
probably forgot about many of them
remember when he creepily told the
French president's wife that she was in
good shape or or when his tacky Golf
Resort was touted on the State
Department website or when he shoved the
prime minister of Montenegro out of the
way and a nato event look how proud of
himself Ian's look Brown Diaz you should
at least have to know that Montenegro is
a country before making a move that says
suck it Montenegro and there were also
quieter but no less alarming moments
like when he explained how hard he's
been fighting to bring clean coal back
without appearing to understand what
that actually is it's just been
announced that a second brand-new coal
mine where they're going to take out
clean coal meaning they're taking out
call they're going to clean it is
opening in the state of Pennsylvania is
it possible that Trump is well versed in
and is referring to flue gas
desulphurization fluidized bed
combustion and selective catalytic
reduction sure it's possible but let's
agree it's considerably more likely that
he thinks you just take a bunch of coal
and scrub a dub it with a big ol sponge
oh yeah that's right I'm saying the
president fundamentally doesn't has
dander what he's talking about
and you know what that means we've got
it
I thought we got in that time all right
that's better okay what do you think I
don't hate myself too all right
the point is tonight let's pull back
from the daily Trump induced chaos and
take a look at the norms that his
presidency has violated they're not the
obvious ones like the fact that he never
released his tax returns or that his own
daughter and son-in-law work in the
White House although admittedly I am
using the word work there so generously
that I should be able to deduct it as a
charitable donation on my taxes or that
instead of putting his assets into a
blind trust to help reduce conflicts of
interest he simply showed America that
he has many large stacks of paper
presumably containing the sentence I
can't believe I'm getting away with this
printed 750,000 times
No instead we're gonna talk about
Trump's assault on something even more
basic the norms governing how our
leaders engage with us and how in turn
that affects the way that we engage with
one another it's why even the notion of
getting him can feel so hopelessly
futile and let's first stipulate that it
definitely doesn't help this so often
what Trump says is complete nonsense we
often read transcripts of Trump speeches
and it's something that everyone should
actually do once in a while because when
you strip away
he's blindly confident entertaining
delivery and just read his words it is
staggering how incoherent he is here is
a word-for-word reading of a speech
where he talked about the Iran nuclear
deal you look at the nuclear deal the
thing that really bothers me
it would have been so easy and it's not
as important as these lives are nuclear
is so powerful my uncle explained that
to me many many years ago the power and
that was 35 years ago he would explain
the power of what's going to happen and
he was right who would have thought but
when you look at what's going on with
the four prisoners now it used to be
three now it's for both limitless
now I would have said it's all on the
messenger fellas and it is fellas
because you know they don't they haven't
figured that the women are smarter right
now than the men so you know it's going
to take them about another 150 years but
the Persians are great negotiators the
Iranians are great negotiators so and
they they just killed they just killed
us is not a functional use of
language that is a drunk driver crashing
a pickup truck full of alphabet soup
trucks actual speech patterns sound like
when you write a long text by choosing
only the predictive text your iPhone
suggests for you seriously
we wrote a message like that starting
with the words the nuclear and here is
what we got the nuclear test program was
not opposed by the other person who
knows what they want and then the delay
is not being done by any other country
and that is not the only way to make
sure the world can do more things and
things like that and gentlemen and then
the other people who have been told to
leave them alone with their children who
are also very sad meaning an iPhone
would be a more coherent President of
the United States but with Trump we are
familiar enough with his speech patterns
that you get the basic gist of what he's
trying to say the real damage isn't in
how he says things but from three key
techniques that he uses to insulate
himself from criticism and consequence
and if we are not extremely careful all
three could have serious impacts that
far outlast his presidency and let's
start with the first one D legitimizing
the media now Trump has been attacking
the press since he declared his
candidacy and in a broader sense
he's been waging war on the very concept
of truth ever since he first turned to
his mom and said Dada and she said no
I'm mama
and he said fake news and his pants
now the difference now is he's crying
fake news as president of the United
States and he is openly proud of it to
the point that he recently tried to take
ownership of the term itself the media
is is really the word I think one of the
greatest of all terms I've come up with
is fake I guess other people have used
it perhaps over the years but I've never
noticed it
he just took credit for inventing the
term fake news which from the record he
did not meaning what he just said was
technically fake fake News News and you
could imagine him saying well I'm not
the first politician to criticize the
press what about Hillary Clinton
what about Barack Obama what about
Bernie Sanders and that actually brings
us to Trump's second technique something
called what about ISM it's the practice
of changing the subject to someone else
is perceived wrongdoing now Trump does
this all the time most famously when he
was asked why he hadn't forcefully
condemned the neo-nazis in
Charlottesville and this was his
response what about the alt left they
came charging at the as you say the alt
right do they have any semblance of
guilt what about the fact that came
charging that they came charging with
clubs in the hand swinging clubs do they
have any problem well actually no
because a Nazi killing someone with a
car is so heinous any other issues that
might be up for debate under any other
circumstances kind of have to wait their
turn you can be wearing Crocs with socks
but if you're using those soft Crocs to
kick Hitler in the balls do you know
what I'm suddenly not so focused
on the footwear now now this technique
of saying what about is actually an old
Soviet propaganda tool and the reason it
is dangerous is but it's because it
implies that all actions regardless of
context share a moral equivalency and
since nobody is perfect all criticism is
hypocritical and everybody should do
whatever they want it is a depressingly
effective tool which is why on trump's
favorite network you hear it all the
time the mainstream media focused on the
Trump campaign and allegations of
collusion with the Russians but what
about the Democrats possible ties to
Moscow former National Security Advisor
General Michael Flynn investigated for
his private meeting with Russia but what
about Hillary Clinton the media wants to
call into question the credibility and
the trustworthiness of this
administration but what about Benghazi
what about the blatant lies that the
Obama administration told us what about
the fact that Ben Rhodes bragged about
lying to the media and the public about
the Iran deal you know what about the
fact that Jonathan Gruber basically said
the American people was stupid okay stop
stop
because here is the thing none of the
errors those people may have made in the
past excused the Trump administration's
actions a defense attorney could not
stand up in court and say maybe my
client did murder those people but I ask
you this
what about Jeffrey Dahmer what about Al
Capone what about the guy from The
Silence of the Lambs
I rest my case here people I rest my
case it doesn't actually solve a problem
or win an argument the point is just to
muddy the waters which can make the
other side mad and that actually brings
us to Trump's third technique trolling
now trolling itself has been around for
years
it's basically 80% of what happens on
the internet it's it's when a YouTube
commenter says something willfully
provocative like saying I've aged to
like an apple core in a dumpster or that
I look like a pickle with
glasses it doesn't matter whether they
mean any of that the point is just to
get a reaction and to hurt my feelings
which by the way it absolutely does but
but Trump Trump may well be the first
ever troll to be elected president and
that's right I said elected remember
tenth president sprinkles fuzz wizard he
assumed office after William Henry
Harrison died and if you're thinking
hold on sprinkles fuzz wizard was not
America's tenth president really who was
America's tenth president exactly let's
assume I'm right the point is as a troll
Trump often does things that have no
effect other than to piss off his
perceived enemies like when he tweeted
this wrestling gif of himself body
slamming CNN or attacked Mika Brzezinski
by saying she was bleeding badly from a
facelift or as we mentioned earlier
tonight called a leader with nuclear
weapons short and fat and Trump even
once retweeted a claim that he was the
most superior troll on the whole of
Twitter calling it a great compliment
which it is not because sometimes when
you do something that makes a lot of
people mad it's because and bear with me
here you're a dick
[Applause]
urinates in every heating vent and they
get mad at you you're not an epic troll
sticking it to the snowflake you
just some
but the thing is Trump's trolling is not
actually without political value despite
Trump's few real policy accomplishments
to date he has consistently achieved one
thing and that is making his enemies
unhappy and for many Trump supporters
that itself counts as a major victory
just listen to how Fox and Friends
reacted after Trump freaked people out
by standing with military leaders during
rising tensions with North Koreans
suggesting that it was the calm before
the storm
I think he's trolling the media he is I
think he's totally trolling me they do
something like that even the smile and
the wink those of us that are sick of
the status quo the Forgotten men and
women who voted for President Trump want
that town to freak out I want those
reporters but what do you what do you
mean it's beautiful to watch is it why
I'm genuinely serious who benefits from
mass confusion about whether or not
we're about to go to war are there
thousands of unemployed factory workers
across the Midwest going well the plant
closed down and I lost my health care
but somewhere a Washington Post reporter
is scared of dying so things are looking
up maca
judging your political success on how
bad you make other people feel makes
just about as much sense as judging your
success as a zookeeper by how many bears
you wow that is not your job I mean
I guess it's impressive in its own way
but it's definitely not what you're
supposed to be doing and the surest
proof of trolling often comes when a
troll is confronted because that's when
they have to either put up or shut up
you may have heard about cases where
people tracked down the source of
something awful that was posted online
only to find some sullen 15 year
old who just shrugs and goes wooden oh
whoa I wrote that or just did it stop
horse could be so many questions
well that is basically our president now
I'll show you remember when Trump said
that Obama had surveilled him in Trump
Tower tweeting how low has President
Obama gone to tap my phones
watch what happens when he was asked to
justify that well you saw what happened
with surveillance and I think that was
inappropriate what does that mean sir
you can figure that out you see like the
reason I asked as you said he you called
him sick and bad look you can figure it
out yourself
he was very nice to me with words but
and when I was with him but after that
there has been no relationship but you
stand by that claim about I don't say
anything I just you can take it the way
you want okay so let's walk through what
just happened there on the internet he
claimed that his predecessor committed
an extremely serious crime but in person
he is suddenly backing down first saying
Obama was very nice to me with words
then that I don't stand by anything
which is one of the most frightening
lean nihilistic sentences a president
can say I would honestly rather hear
that from a clown holding a knife than a
president because at least when a clown
says I don't stand by anything you think
yeah that kind of makes sense please
make it quick and look it gets worse
because that interview kept going and
Trump was explicitly given the
opportunity to set the record straight
for the fake news media but he flat-out
refused I just wanted to find out that
you're the other president United States
you said he was sick and bad because he
anyway you can take it any way you want
but I'm asking you because you don't
want to do fake news I want to hear you
don't have to ask why not because I have
my own opinions you can have your own
opinions but I want to know your
opinions you're the president the United
States it's enough thank you thank you
very much
okay so there is a lot that is
infuriating about that clip but chunk
going back to his desk and pretending to
work hard is an objectively funny thing
to do that's like your dog avoiding
questions by pretending to do his taxes
you never do this why would you need to
do it now well there is nothing new
about any of these techniques they are
now coming out of the Oval Office which
not only legitimizes them it risks them
spreading and that sadly is happening
last month Congressman Paul Gosar used
all three techniques first he suggested
in an interview that the march in
Charlottesville may have been a false
flag operation created by the left which
is pretty trolli behavior and when
confronted about it he deployed the
other two tools it's all been debunked
there was there was no mark absolutely
not to bunk for whatsoever so speak to
your Z theory that you have put out
there has been debunked it has not been
two-month look at look at what CNN has
talked about with with what's going on
with the Clinton administration right
now with the dossier hardly an aspect in
regards to Devon you're not real news
you're fake news sir everything you've
said has been debunked why are you
continuing to put this out there so he's
basically just copying trunk and if
there is one thing worse than something
terrible it's a cover band of that
terrible thing if Trump is Nickelback
that man is Bickle nack
not as good at it as the original and a
horrible sign that the disease is
spreading the problem is if that becomes
the level of discourse in this country
we are seriously and lastingly
and just this week we saw some of these
techniques pushed to the absolute limit
by the scandal involving Alabama Senate
candidate Roy Moore who has denied
allegations of sexual misconduct with a
14-year old when he was 32 and called
them fake news now what Sean Hannity
then used what about ISM to derail the
discussion about it
this 14-year old girl purportedly
according to the Washington Post told
two of her girlfriends what happened
here's a tough question real-time do you
think Bill Clinton in retrospect was a
predator but that is not what this
discussion is about you might as well
have said here's a tough question if you
had to guess how many lobsters are there
like total in the world is that worth
discussing sure but first let's finish
talking about the Senate candidate who
may have made sexual advances on a child
and look whether Clinton engaged in
predatory behavior is absolutely a
legitimate question but it shouldn't
really inform what we do about Roy Moore
and even if you believe that Democrats
are guilty of a double standard the
solution is not to have no standard
whatsoever that is why it's so important
to train ourselves to identify these
techniques because their natural
endpoint is the erosion of our ability
to decide what's important have an
honest debate and hold one another
accountable and that erosion can be so
gradual that it's difficult to spot it's
like being murdered by a sloth it
happens very slowly and you might not
notice until it's too late
listen this is all very bleak I cannot
pretend that it isn't which is why it is
so important to take some hope from this
year's small victories like the Muslim
ban being blocked by the court after
massive public protests to appeal
Obamacare stalling thanks in part to
people pressuring their lawmakers and
just this week
Java's week in Virginia voters rejected
Ed Gillespie for governor after he ran a
trump style dog-whistle campaign and
that is encouraging because it's nice to
know that if you use Trump tactics in a
Virginia gubernatorial election you do
not get to be Governator
now further down the ballot there
Tuesday also mark the defeat of Bob
Marshall who earlier this year proposed
a so-called bathroom bill he lost to
Danica Rome who will now be Virginia's
[Applause]
is already markedly different
Danica you were running against Robert
Marshall and incumbent 13 term incumbent
he's also a man who referred to himself
as Virginia's chief homophobe he refused
to debate you during the campaign you
have anything you want to say to him
come January delegate Marshall will deal
on my constituents and I'm not gonna
disrespect my own constituents he openly
disrespected her but given the
opportunity she chose not to respond by
tweeting I'll fight for bob's rights to
use any bathroom he wants but it's too
late
he already the bed on election day
sad it's nice it's nice not to have that
and look Tuesday's results should not
make you complacent they are absolutely
no guarantee that the midterms will turn
out at all well that is why though you
should take these moments of
encouragement to help you keep going
because the trump presidency is
basically a marathon it's painful it's
pointless and the majority of you didn't
even agree to run it you would just
signed up by your dumbest friend
and the fact is we're not even at Mile 6
right now or possibly even mile 3 so
there is a long way to go and though
you're exhausted and your whole body is
screaming for you to give up and your
nipples are chafing for some reason the
stakes are too high for any of us to
stop and I do realize that I'm saying
that as we're about to stop doing shows
for the year but but here's the thing we
won't actually be going away entirely
you might remember earlier this year we
used our catheter cowboy to try and get
information to the president in the ad
brakes of Fox and Friends well Trump is
still watching that show and we know
this because the Times wrote a generally
negative piece about its enormous
influence on him and because of that
called it the most powerful TV show in
America a sentiment that the hosts were
very excited about this program the
program you're watching is according to
the New York Times the most powerful TV
show in America why Steve because we
have the best viewers yes no absolutely
don't saying that we have the best views
fighting that
you guys are fine the best audience
belongs to Ellen because this is how
they greet her she is now
none of you did that when I came
out just 45 minutes after that
information was on Fox Trump tweeted Wow
the failing New York Times said about
Fox & Friends the most powerful TV show
in America so information goes right
from that show into his brain which is
terrible because we would genuinely be
better off if Trump was getting daily
briefings from an actual Fox and his
friends a hedgehog and a weasel with its
head stuck in a tin can
but if Trump is going to keep watching
that show we are going to spend our
hiatus sneaking information through our
catheter Cowboys so so so a number of
commercials are going to be airing on
Fox News over the next few months here
is the first one the tinted catheter
patients I'm a professional cowboy I use
catheters and there's two things I know
I don't like pain when I calf and the
term clean coal doesn't refer to the
physical act of cleaning ability to be
impossible
coal is cold clean coal is a marketing
term the coal industry came up with for
stuff like carbon capture and
sequestration an expensive process that
shown limited results at best
also Frederick Douglass is dead later
this week and keep an eye out for more
of them because that cowboy has got a
bunch up his sleeve the US Virgin
Islands has a government not a president
here's a fun fact there's actually no
federal law against this thanks to
something called the First Amendment
just because Jared Kushner is smarter
than you doesn't mean that he's smart
the nay
BIRT actually seems nobody I was
disappointed too there are many non gold
decor schemes that are actually very
appealing during an eclipse don't do
this buddy this can't be that hard
Nazis bad one fish two fish red fish arm
of the executive branch that should
operate free from White House
interference so as to avoid politically
motivated prosecution Donald Donald I
don't think he's getting any of this
that's all for now Donald see you
tomorrow and remember if you're not
enjoying there's no shame in Clinton
[Applause]